la extirpación quirúrgica del tumor
forma parte del tratamiento para la
mayoría de los casos de cáncer de mama
existen varias opciones quirúrgicas el
médico le ayudará a decidir cuál es la
mejor para su situación además de la
cirugía de mama es posible que se deban
extraer algunos o todos los ganglios
linfáticos debajo del brazo
existen dos procedimientos quirúrgicos
principales para el cáncer de mama el
primero es la cirugía de conservación de
la mama o tumorectomía que siempre se
acompaña con tratamiento de radiación
el segundo es la mastectomía que
consiste en la extirpación de toda la
mama se puede combinar con la cirugía de
reconstrucción mamaria
en ambos procedimientos es posible que
se deban extraer algunos ganglios
linfáticos
una tumorectomía conserva el aspecto de
la mama se extirpa el tumor junto con el
margen de tejido circundante en este
procedimiento
el cirujano hace una incisión en la piel
y retira el tumor con un margen de
tejido sano
se envía a un patólogo para que lo
analice y asegurarse de que no haya
cáncer en el margen circundante de
tejido
la herida se cierra con suturas
en una mastectomía se extirpa toda la
mama
en una mastectomía simple solo se
extirpa el tejido mamario
el cirujano comienza con una incisión
para quitar un óvalo de piel que incluye
el pezón
el tejido de la mama y el músculo
subyacente se separan de la piel y se
extraen para análisis
por último el cirujano inserta drenajes
para prevenir la acumulación de líquidos
una mastectomía radical modificada es un
procedimiento en el que se extrae el
tejido mamario junto con algunos o todos
los ganglios linfáticos debajo del brazo
además de la tumorectomía o la
mastectomía se suele realizar una
biopsia del ganglio linfático centinela
se puede realizarse un examen clínico o
un estudio por imagen no muestra
evidencia de que el cáncer se haya
extendido a los ganglios linfáticos el
objetivo de la biopsia es identificar y
examinar los primeros ganglios
linfáticos con drenaje de la mama para
asegurarse de que el cáncer no se haya
propagado a ese lugar para ello se
inyecta un tinte en la mama para
determinar que hagan los linfáticos son
los ganglios linfáticos centinela el
cirujano retira entre uno y tres
ganglios linfáticos centinela para
análisis si estos ganglios no tienen
cáncer es poco probable que los demás
ganglios linfáticos lo tengan si estos
ganglios linfáticos tienen cáncer el
resto de los ganglios linfáticos debajo
del brazo denominados ganglios
linfáticos axilares también pueden tener
cáncer en este caso se puede recomendar
una disección completa de los ganglios
linfáticos axilares para retirar la
mayor parte de los nudos en esta área
una opción adicional en el caso de una
mastectomía es la reconstrucción de la
mama extraída para la reconstrucción de
la mama se utiliza en implantes o tejido
de otras partes del cuerpo como del
abdomen o de las nalgas para crear una
nueva mama
en algunos casos el cirujano también
puede preservar el pezón
la reconstrucción también se puede
realizar inmediatamente después de la
mastectomía lo que se conoce como
reconstrucción inmediata o en una fecha
posterior llamada reconstrucción
retrasada
si está considerando la cirugía de
reconstrucción su médico puede ayudarle
a decidir qué método es mejor para su
situación